the election is over
and we have the results and it has been
a a historic election
we have for the first time a nationalist
a republican
first minister elected in the person of
michelle o'neill and the job now is to
get to work we need to see the immediate
formation of an executive
michelle o'neill ratified as first
minister
and
an appointment of a deputy first
minister to that position and any
tactics of delay from the dup
any grandstanding by them
any gamesmanship by the british
government who may wish to use the north
of ireland in a bargaining chip
in terms of their wider engagement with
the european union over the protocol
would be clearly intolerable and must
not happen
so we're here with you today after a
long campaign and a historic uh result
absolutely resolute and determined to
get the job done and to ensure that
everybody in a spirit of partnership
gets back to work in an executive led by
the first republican first minister in
the north of ireland michelle o'neill
[Applause]
well as mary lou says kid mila fulche to
all of our returned mlas and
congratulations to you but also to your
families because as we all know when we
contest elections it takes all that
support that we have at home as well so
well done to them also
special welcome to the many media press
corps joined us this afternoon
also
so we now have
had the election and the people have
spoken and they've spoken very clearly
in this election
the message is one of hope it's also one
of optimism for the future where
political leaders work together and they
make politics work
that's my commitment as a political
leader and as an incoming first
minister the electorate also demands
that the parties get back down to
business to elect a speaker to sit in
the assembly to have it function to
appoint a first minister a deputy first
minister to form a new executive
in order so that we can take the urgent
decisions that are required to invest
one billion pounds extra in our health
service to allocate over 330 million
pounds to help people who are burdened
with the struggle and cost of raise cost
of living rises
and also to agree a programme for
government and a budget
so there can be no excuses there can be
no attempt by the dep or by anyone else
to punish the public and leave workers
and families high and dry now or in the
time
ahead i have said that this election
represents a very significant moment of
change
it really is a defining moment for our
politics and for all of our people
it also presents us with an opportunity
an opportunity to re-imagine the
relationships in this society on the
basis of fairness on the basis of
equality and on the basis of social
justice
as a first minister for all i intend to
work with those from different political
perspectives through partnership and not
division
i will provide leadership which is
inclusive which celebrates diversity
which guarantees rights and equality for
those who have been excluded
discriminated against and ignored in the
past
what we want is for this assembly this
executive to adopt a culture of civility
of mature politics that's dormant here
and a focus on our shared priorities
our mission must be to deliver the
cost-11 crisis that's burned down on so
many people
it must be to deal with health education
and our far-reaching improvements in our
economy in order to create and sustain
growth good jobs good wages for everyone
right across our community
for me it will be a special honor to
serve as first minister and i also know
this comes with huge responsibility
through word indeed i will be a first
minister for all faithfully serving the
whole community
i was born in cork but i was rare in
toronto i'm a proud ulster woman and i
am very proud of our place on this
island on these islands which is a rich
tapestry of languages of heritage and
culture including the orange and green
and also the rainbow of cultures under
multiculturalism
i think the scale of what has been
achieved and accomplished since the
advent of the good friday agreement 24
years ago has resulted in the
transformation of our society and in
particular our border communities
but we also have much much more to do in
order to prosper and all to reach our
full potential
this includes advancing peace and
reconciliation and eradicating the
cancer of sectarianism in our society
our society has suffered for long enough
we must hail the wounds of the past
so in the common times we have much to
do
today i have met we have met with the
british secretary of state i've spoken
with the taoiseach i'll be engaging with
other party leaders and my message is
clear as democrats the dup but also the
british government must accept and
respect the democratic outcome of this
election
brinkmanship will not be tolerated where
the north of ireland becomes colonial
damage in a game of chicken with the
european commission
responsibility for finding solutions to
the protocol to make it smooth
implementation lie with boris johnson
and the eu
but make no mistake we and our business
community here will not be held to
ransom
this means that applying the good friday
agreement in all of its parts an
assembly executive north-south
ministerial council and an east-west
structure without delay and no further
interruption
our collective task
is to work together to solve the
problems that are facing our society
we must apply the full powers and
resources of the executive on the
assembly to address the major issues of
the day facing them whom we all
represent
it's time for us all as political
leaders to have the courage to step
forward with unity of purpose and
determination to deliver a stable power
sure and coalition one that works and
mostly one that delivers so friends now
is the time to embrace the future we
certainly have much work to do and many
people to represent
the people want government and we all
want change and i am committed to both
germany